I've already decided, so I'm going to play with Keema curry.Today
's set looks delicious.I
asked if I could change the sashi babo to chicken tikka.Yes,
I'm sorry, I'll go tomorrow.Well, I'll have Keema curry and plain
naan.  One more, and today's set.
Can I change this shish kebab to chicken tika? Yes, you can. Well, please
change it to chicken tika.
What would you like to have with the naan? Yes,
I haven't decided yet.
Which do you recommend, the cheese naan or this morai naan?
Yes, both are delicious,
but the cheese naan is a little heavy, so I
prefer the morai naan.
That's why I
said it because I thought it wasn't. That's why I
said it was from a while ago. But what's the
point of that statement? It's just that the store clerk is
saying that, but the store clerk said it
was.  I already know that
because the store clerk told me that, so I'm
not saying that I don't know.Then
why do you say that a third party knows?I
know, but this person just said this.  The
reason why I do this is because I think too much about the flow of the conversation.The
nuances of how I do things like this are the
same thing.That's why I act even if a third party doesn't suddenly tell me what to do.I'm just
encouraging the conversation.That's exactly what I do.
If you don't encourage them, this person won't take
action.The statement doesn't contain any new information, so I
can only interpret it that way.No, that's not
it.That's why I feel like I'm being made fun of in front of other people, and I really do
n't like it.
Okay, let's go, let's go, yeah, yeah, yeah, that's right. During a conversation, I
say "Japan, yup, yup," and wave it at the other person. It's
just a signal that it's OK to continue doing the same thing. Well, maybe it's true,
but I don't really
like it.  It's not the right way to say it,
so please hold back just a little. No, it's too much trouble. I
know it's troublesome, but please, this is how
I feel. You shut
up,
til.